ich bin da 12 und stellet er solche
szenen alter leute machen was dicker
nein er wird was glaubt willkommen beim
neuen video und zwar wie ich mir gedacht
einkommen kam es doch einfach mal eine
ganz alten videos raus ich weiß nicht ob
das so eine gute idee war weil die sind
schon echt extrem scheiße peinlich und
scheiße aber was soll es auf jeden fall
auch mega witz ich fühle mich jetzt
vielleicht nicht so aber für euch auf
jeden fall da bin ich mir ganz sicher
ich bin also zwölf oder dreizehn sieht
zwar aus wie neunaber bin schon zwölf
oder 13
und ich weiß nicht was ich mir dabei
gedacht habe als ich diese videos
gedreht habe vor allem wir hatten
wirklich aus so 70 36 dislike city
müssten eigentlich zwei leicht- und 5
milliarden des lecks haben wie viele
menschen gibt es 8 8 milliarden des
lakes egal ich will mich gar nicht
drüber aufregen wir fangen direkt man
ihr werdet sehen was ich meine und ich
würde in dem video das ihr euch jetzt
zeige ging es übrigens so darum so der
kamera dieses wort lappen so richtig
raus und ich wollte aufklären
das macht doch gar keinen sinn ich muss
dazu noch sagen ich habe das video
wirklich schon ganz lange nicht mehr
gesehen ich will sagen dass es locker
schon so dreier her aber wir dann jetzt
ja
irgendwo ist ganz nah ich mich ist auch
cool warum erst bei uns nämlich so nah
an der kamera zweitens was hab ich dafür
frage alter bank das sieht einfach
scheiße auf das sieht einfach nur
scheiße
nein ich bin da 12 und stellt er solche
szenen da alter erneute man das ding
rein was sag nicht du bist auch einer
von dieser sorte die ständig das wort
klappern in den mund nimmt er schon
wieder so zweideutig nicht so komplett
überhaupt nicht gespielt aber gut
das sollte jetzt lustig sein versteht
also ich bin nicht ich weiß eigentlich
soll es ja so viel wie eine beleidigung
sein
die meisten sehen ist ja auch so an aber
wenn man mal kurz nachdenkt und einige
kurt der als zwölfter
ich glaube ich hatte da noch kein iq der
höher als 15 war
warum habe ich bitte solche videos
hochgeladen man ich checke das nicht und
was ich dazu noch sagen kann ich fand
die früher wirklich extrem gut
ich habe mich dafür richtig gefeiert da
kann das weiß ich konnte und ich mache
meine oslo ging mit 13 und jetzt jetzt
kommt mein heftigst effekt den habe ich
früher immer eingebaut fast auch leute
film ab und dann immer diese themen
ablenken
soweit ich weiß ist dass hier oder auch
einfach das daneben
dieses schöne gesicht mit den langen
hässlichen hahn ist auch ein doppel
ach ja ich habe vor kurzem erfahren dass
es eine baumart gibt die auf den namen
lappen trägt nachdem ich dies
habe habe ich mich erst mal kaputt
gelacht ich weiß nachdem ich das gesehen
gelacht vor allem die ich das rüber
gebracht hatten ich weiß nicht wieso ich
weiß nicht wieso hält doch klar warum du
dich kaputt gelacht und warum nennt man
baum lappen ist genauso als würde den
baum lutscher nennen oder so heute diese
zwölfjährigen kinder die diese übeltaten
beleidigen rausholen gegen mich so auf
den keks aber ich war anscheinend selber
so zum schluss fragen ob ihr auch auf
dieses wort laden benutzt schreibt das
doch einfach mal kurz und in die
kommentare
schreib doch mal in die kommentare
benutzt ihr auch auf das muss klappen
und soll zeugt von der video
beschreibung und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten video haut rein leute schaut
euch das mal das video ging eine minute
50 was ist das bitte will ich heute ein
video drehen dass eine minute 50 gehen
wird das kannst du doch nicht hochladen
alter da wirst du doch was bringt denn
ein video was eine minute 50 lage ist
gar nichts oder vor allem so ein video
mit diesem inhalt und scheiße diese
leute die das gezeigt haben guckt euch
doch lieber eine minute 50 lagen die
wand an dass es interessanter als dieses
video das ist einfach nur scheiße also
ich geb's zu meine videos früher waren
echt beschissen meiner meinung nach ihr
könnt ihr mal schreiben fandet ihr okay
fandet ihr ist süß vielleicht auch nicht
was hier und ganz süß oder findet ihr es
einfach krank ansonsten kann ihnen auch
sagen ich habe auch noch so ein video
von mir gefunden
das ist eine parodie auf katy perry i
kissed a girl ich weiß ja überzeugen
doch kennt er das schon ganz alt das ist
echt doch die krönung vom ganzen sag ich
mal der ist auf diese parodie war ich
früher wirklich extrem stolz und ich
habe auch wirklich so den sound davon
richtig hart gefeiert dass ich das gut
hinbekommen
aber wenn man sich das heute gibt ich
würde mich dafür am liebsten erschießen
ohne scheiß das ist so kacke also leute
wenn dieses video sagen wir mal 12.000
geht oder so dann kommt als nächstes
hier katy perry i kissed a girl schaue
ich mir an und kommentiert das ein
bisschen ansonsten hoffe ich natürlich
dass wieder hat euch gefallen wenn ja
dann hat sich halt gefallen ist ja klar
instagram snap hinweis eingeblendet hier
oben links geht es aber weiter mit neuen
im letzten video
da ging es so wobei mädchen immer lügen
könnt ihr auch gerne mal vorbeischauen
habe ich so ein bisschen ein paar dinge
kommentiert die immer gesagt habe wir
sehen uns sondern
nun hat wieder am nächsten donnerstag
schon gegen die abendschau